new travel permits for Leila Maajid six
months ago the Iraqi flew to Germany she
walked for 15 days across the Balkans
now she is waiting at Tegel Airport for
her departure flight together with other
refugees she wants to go back to Iraq it
was her own choice we were not treated
well we did not have enough food nor
enough sleep a lot of refugees here had
similar experiences they tried to apply
for asylum without success most of them
thought it would be easier to start a
new life in Germany the asylum process
for Iraqis is way too slow I cannot get
my family over here and I haven't
received a permit to stay yet at the
airport hamid majid is organising the
departure of his fellow citizens today
is especially hectic half an hour before
the flight he has to make a last-minute
booking for an additional 20 refugees
since October we have over 50 refugees a
week that want to return to Iraq in
January these numbers doubled last week
we had 86 today it's going to be 92 and
this is a harsh reality for some
refugees waiting in the cold instead of
work and a new life some asylum seekers
have to wait for months before they even
registered still many don't want to give
up
actually in the flash I have been here
every day I have been waiting all day
long for my appointment but so far I
haven't been able to get in it's only a
few meters to Alejandra's Travel Agency
for weeks Iraqis have been coming to him
to book their return tickets home the
one-way flight to Iraq costs around 300
euros I always ask the clients when they
book their tickets why do you want to go
back
well we imagined a different reality
here they say we have to wait too long
for our permits and sleep in shelters
and I always say you have been through
so much already in Iraq and on the way
to Germany you could have waited to see
what Germany is really like then how do
you really see it happen come on so
cooking village dirge hunters but Leyla
Majeed doesn't want to wait any longer
her homesickness and disappointment
proved too much to bear in only five
hours she will be back in Iraq